la reina isabel personalmente planeó los
detalles de su funeral aunque debo
contarles que en la familia real hay una
persona encargada única y exclusivamente
de planear los funerales de los monarcas
es el duque de norfolk así que la reina
isabel personalmente planeó este funeral
eligió la abadía de westminster porque
aquí podría caber la mayor número de
invitados son 2000 entre ellos 300 200
invitados del público elegidos
minuciosamente porque tuvieron de una u
otra manera una historia personal con la
reina isabel fueron condecorados por la
monarca e hicieron parte de las cerca de
500 organizaciones de caridad de las que
isabel segunda era la patrona pero esta
abadía de westminster también es
importante porque aquí se han realizado
todas las coronaciones de reinas y de
reyes desde mil
996 pero además ha sido el lugar de las
bodas también además del de la reina de
la princesa anna la única hija mujer de
isabel 2a
el duque de york el príncipe andrés y
más recientemente el de katy de william
hoy los duques de gales en donde el 11 y
también ustedes maría clara tendrán una
imagen y un recuerdo bien conmovedor
porque aquí también fue el funeral de
estado de la princesa diana de gales en
1997 las notas del piano de elton john
en candle in the wind retumbaron en este
edificio y robaron lágrimas en todo el
mundo si luisa y precisamente usted nos
menciona que habrá dos mil invitados
dentro de estos dos mil invitados se
cuentan quinientos jefes de estado
incluyendo el presidente de eeuu joe
biden y el presidente francés emmanuel
majo cuéntanos qué se sabe de quiénes
son estos invitados y sobre todo de que
está en juego en la geopolítica ante la
visita de tantos presidentes y tantos
primeros ministros
si maria clara es sin duda el lugar
donde los grandes líderes del mundo
quieren estar quieren salir en la foto
del funeral de estado de isabel segunda
como lo mencionas el presidente de eeuu
el presidente de francia el emperador de
japón los primeros ministros de los
países del commonwealth son 56 desde
está la poderosa inglaterra hasta
territorios en el caribe como jamaica
hay invitados de todo el mundo está el
presidente de brasilia el bolsonaro
otros países latinoamericanos enviaron a
sus cancilleres se sabe que de colombia
está el canciller a álvaro leyva y la
primera dama de la nación verónica
alcocer también hay representantes de 20
monarquías del mundo no solamente
europeas pero como mencionas este
funeral de estado nos muestra la
influencia política que ha tenido isabel
en 70 años y 7 meses de reinado la
influencia que sigue teniendo la casa
real británica y sobre todo maría clara
nos muestra que isabel es una reina
universo probablemente la única que
hemos conocido millones y millones de
personas en todo el mundo